let's rock and roll god damnit through
it I'm pumped I got I got a lot drank
too much coffee this morning yeah but
you know what I'm even more pump because
I got Aubrey Marcus sitting sitting
Rajeev Lal Salaam real I read his book
on the day on your life optimize
practices for walk you guys want to
learn how to [ __ ] walk work learn
[ __ ] train oh yes weight sleep or
have sex you bastards here I like the I
love the cello the front that's great by
the way his wife is on the back
couldn't be amazing water light movement
deep breath deep freeze more fat less
sugar or don't eat essential supplements
drive time a lifetime the power plants
power plants doing work eat a weird
lunch [ __ ] the bind bind neural power
nap I'm at training reset and reconnect
eat dinner like a king more better sex
we've got we had people pitches folks
before and I don't think we had our boy
Sebastian on here
yeah everyone goes oh let's do a book
Jesus Christ I had to get honeydicked
into it honestly like it's people kept
telling me like oh man it'll be easy you
know we'll get we'll get you some help
the problem is I'm a writer right so
like there was help available but then I
couldn't [ __ ] stand when somebody
else would try and like me always an
idea or prose or something like that and
I was just like it just felt gross so I
ended up writing it and then I'd look
back at it and be like oh did a [ __ ]
child write this and then I'd rewrite it
and I'd rewrite it I mean I paid the
blood price you paid the blood price I
made the blood price here's the thing
I've like wide like it's always like
write a book we're like oh I want to
write about this then you look at the
book and you know whap see Brian I know
you well Mike that makes sense but it's
tough to figure out like what you want
to do with the book because I think that
was our biggest thing cos Bryant and
when we were out for book you know I
just like you have a cool cover I'm
gonna buy that book you have a hot girl
in the back I'm buying the book Brian
likes to look into the pages and
actually read so when we got me the book
and egos of all the people I know I
think you'll probably read this thing
yeah
right there yeah I read right through it
so that I think that stuff's part for
people especially when you have your
you're in so many lanes it's tough to
figure out kind of have that kind of
challenge this all into one book that
make sense yeah totally it was trying to
harness all of this information because
total human optimization this whole
thing I live it's about living a
complete full life and how do you put
that in a book and I think the key
moment was realizing we're just gonna
compress this into one single [ __ ]
day we're gonna take an entire life and
put it in a day with each step like part
of a process what's not to sunrise
waking up exactly so all you have to
focus on is just doing one day like like
the best in the world would do you know
and then if you just focus on one day
one day is doable and each practice each
part of that day is also doable so it's
not like we're asking a 30 day program a
40 day program or some big ask it's just
like alright just try with all this
stuff for one day you got clear
prescriptions you got clear like
research backing it it's it's easy to do
in that way if you just relax into the
process and just shorten the amount of
commitment that you need to just all
right I'm gonna try this for one day and
see what changed well what I appreciate
about sort of you know on it and the
whole thing and and even in the book is
that I'm very aware that there's a
shitload of research that's gone into it
and this is what this is why I know that
I don't just take anything for face
value so if you have this go away
recovery protein or you have alpha brain
or you have shroom tech immune I if you
if you actually go online in today's
marketplace people do their research and
they'll take you apart if you're not
Australian they will destroy you but you
can see that people who are really
following this stuff so a guy I know who
was studying the gut biome is getting
his PhD he was in medical school and he
he said actually on its total gut health
from all my research my contemporary
research they've got at prop that's
probably the best product on the market
right now or when you had that recovery
protein it was goat way I was like
that's so interesting because they're
finding that regular way because of the
protein and holstein American cows is
really hard to digest it's a type of
protein it's not even that lactose
type of routine and of course you guys
have got well yeah no doubt I like this
but the matter is this is the longest
reefer island ever but no tell them
about when you took doubt those
mushrooms what did your so yeah so so so
was my mushroom the shroom tech immune I
I was like taking that when I get a cold
and I swear to god it works I mean look
I'm not a big supplement guy yeah but I
would take it and I would everybody my
family be sick and I wouldn't get sick
so then I started doing some research on
it I was like oh this shit's got chalk
on mushrooms it's got astrologist Excel
has come that actually boosts your
helper T problems when you've got an
autoimmune disease you might want to be
careful cuz your skin goes show me skin
and I well it's gotten better but that's
that's that's way better than it was
good it's flaking off that was my
favorite that's the poison ivy shame I
[Music]
went from smooth and and forty looking
to middle aged red and BA leaking like a
snake oh thank you chocolate you like
this yeah the immune system is a funny
thing because it's our biggest ally and
also like our biggest nemesis all the
allergic reactions everything is
basically our immune system attacking
itself do you feel Center relief out to
fish in this book oh man did you have to
do the audible version too and the tire
just might be the worst post it was the
hardest work I've ever done yeah
everyone was reading like four days in a
row just locked into two producers in
your ear telling you they could tell me
if my stomach was gurgling
got a little stomach in there we're
gonna have to take that from the top a
mic ticket from the top do you ever do
you ever have to say a word over and
over it eventually sensor and I was like
watch my mouth my mouth would get tired
and I couldn't form words for a little
while I have to take like a walk yeah
it's a muscle yeah your voice your vocal
cords are a muscle and your you it's a
very muscular process which if you have
to help me because we were doing I doing
this thing for below the belt this week
ago one that yours on Showtime I do all
these wrestler WWE promos so I'd watch
Ric Flair they had the exact outfit now
how do the promo just like they do it
and I was yelling and probably was I
brought Brian said to give me like notes
and stuff and I was yelling by the end
of it my voice was awesome
shoot a commercial after that mean
brand-new yeah and their bosses you're
like can you do it and I was like I'll
try Brenda no nope nope no no when he
needs at least an hour and like dude
what I do
Tabata sets of cunnilingus in theater
school or any anything you do any
performance yeah you know yeah you'd
always wonder when you were younger why
you were doing all this voice work you'd
be doing like you learned how to relax
her voice and there were all these
manipulations and when you sing it's you
know when you watch somebody like
Christina Aguilera blah blah that's
god-given talent she's been training her
voice since she was three years old she
couldn't do a show back in the back I
thought about that because I did these
promos which or 30 minutes total maybe
45 minutes and I'm like how the [ __ ]
that is Ric Flair do it night after
night yeah else's you have to study he
worked I remember the first time I
auditioned I was in New York City I was
a young actor 23 or something and I was
very nervous and I went to audition for
I think the Dramatic Academy of Dramatic
Arts or something like that and you you
would come in with a comedic monologue
and a dramatic monologue
oh oh that's funny and the other was you
know yeah Tom when I saw you standing on
that that hill up there I knew you're
gonna die and you're just you're and
you're holding your ID because it's cold
it's so embarrassing anyway long story
search and these three rather gay
theater theater aficionados who ran the
program and I never got here a ponytail
is very well dressed man and he said
have you had any voice lessons and I
said no and he said mmm it shows yes
your voice needs a total rehashing brace
man and that was the beginning it's all
it's a free look into it I'm sure with
your book looking the stuff and that
that's what you can get out of the book
but anything we talk to professionals
it's like just unraveling [ __ ] hey
doctor it's like an onion man that's so
much [ __ ] going on yes yeah I mean what
would the book there's the research that
you can do you know online and then
there's the practice
you can actually try it you know like
sometimes a research looks good and it's
like [ __ ] 12 grams of guar gum will
slow down your blood sugar then you try
to eat 12 grams of guar gum a night look
it's a nightmare you know what I mean
here come so it's like some of the
research they'll say like have 2 grams
of sodium bicarbonate like our baking
soda and then you try it and you're like
or like 2 tablespoons and you're like no
I just [ __ ] my pants so it was a
combination of going we have like 300
clinical references but a lot of stuff
we had to ditch because we would try it
you know me Kyle Kingsbury all the
athletes in our gym everybody
we'd experiment be like this is not
possible like okay sodium bicarbonate
great for aerobic performance no I'm
gonna [ __ ] your pants every time yeah so
like what do you get the shitty cardi
well hands-on we could you talk about it
was it sex life in there yeah because
the boys are like oh hell yeah that's
the only Bible part of it yes leave just
that little sections to go step of his
erectus just hims like steak it is [ __ ]
with [ __ ] all people are gonna be
pointing any other questions people
think it's gonna be a bunch of tips and
stuff really mostly what I'm talking
about is how the ego is the worst thing
in the bedroom like when you come in
with a big throbbing ego that's the
[ __ ] biggest turnoff because that
prevents you from communicating that
prevents you from identifying areas
where you could get better from like
relaxing into the moment and just
actually enjoying another guy with a fat
squat over here so that I don't go in
like yeah I hope this works out okay I'm
humbly [ __ ] now suck on hey I'm a piece
of [ __ ] I usually don't do this
I hate myself now sucker mean news my
dad was never around what just up to on
different foods you can eat because it
comes after the dinner chapter different
foods you can eat to enhance nitric
oxide since you have better give a
sexual performance arugula watermelon
beets Swiss chard dark chocolate red
wine that's a dope-ass salad [ __ ] yeah
actually have a salad in there called
like well we called it the bonus out I
don't know if that made fine hook god I
call it dicks out look to your recipes
they're great yeah you have some of that
to support it and it'll help with any
typo you know nitric oxide controls the
blood flow so it's good for a pump like
those supplements NO explode what
they're talking about is releasing more
nitric oxide so that your muscles can
get that bigger pump it's why it's
illegal to take in sports yeah and I
don't wanna be too small if you're
fighting well because in your hands is
your blood flow so you have better
cardio if you take out you know dick
pills yeah and then but for sex it's the
same thing I mean you have valves
capillaries that you want to open full
whether you're a guy or a girl you know
the more humble and blood flow you have
more circulation you have the more
pleasurable it's gonna be so it's a
combination of like the mindset stuff
with the physical stuff and what you can
do just by like changing some of the
foods you eat or ordering that beet
salad you're gonna perform better they
this is embarrassed it's a so a mature
question but these these just say like
pineapple and stuff would make your [ __ ]
taste better that's that's right I've
heard that no I didn't I've heard that I
think that's there's there stuff like
that you actually go to the research and
then you don't find anything yeah
there's no that's yeah yeah that's why
when I come I go here comes Hawaii and
I'm just talking a map of Hawaii he
likes wine punch ah I smell like Hawaii
and then there was the other counter
thing that said like girl girls got in
their head that tomatoes made their
[ __ ] smell bad oh really
not I don't think that's true what's
that tomatoes make your [ __ ] smell bad
Tomatoes so I'll say this about Tomatoes
that's really fascinating so so they
actually know for sure that so the
Italians what I'm gonna make
Minna sauce they take off the skin they
take the seeds out
remember tomato's not indigenous to
Europe they come from a new world and
for 200 years the Italian really eat
tomatoes and then along comes tomato
sauce but you take the skin off and you
take the seeds out my grandmother would
do it and all that takes really well the
reason for that is custom custom has a
way of kind of reflecting there's a
scientific method to everything the way
you prepare food usually has some health
benefits to it so when the Peruvians
make quinoa they have a three-step
process so you don't have the protein to
lectins because some plants don't wanna
be eaten and they create proed so all
the sort of lectins the proteins that
your body doesn't like to absorb are in
the seeds and the skin of the tomato so
if you want a lot of customs yeah they
will they will roasting it cooking it
was very helpful as well the [ __ ]
around in America where there's tomato
juice is Americans or brown rice and
brown rice if you read all of China all
of Japan all of the Middle East
everybody you can think of all polished
there I say nobody eats brown rice
except for the Americans what a surprise
yeah we're also the only idiots who
still have egg whites on the healthy
menu how crazy you're walking in for
low-fat yogurt or mellow I freaked out I
see that do my girl brought some home
for my son all the oh my god oh my god
yeah common place it's absolute it's
absolutely necessary and if you're not
eating fat you're probably [ __ ] fat
you know that's just the bottom line of
it and you know we obviously go into
that in the book and you have we've
talked about the great job in the book
but it's a it's this crazy paradigm
where we're unwinding all of this
[ __ ] the brown rice the low fat the
cholesterol the bro science policies
abroad it kind of grows like panty bro
science it was like hippy science
there's some some crazy idea where
there's a really interesting there's a
book called why we get fat and what to
do about it by Gary tab was a journalist
a science journalist and he actually
traces the lineage about this so in in
the world it's really kind of
fascinating before world war ii german
scientist and Austrian scientist had
come up with the idea that so much of
weight gain was hormonal and how you ate
had the kind of the kind of calories you
took and had a different hormonal
response right so if you eat broccoli
and protein and and you eat and some
high fat you eat avocado protein and
Brock your body is gonna produce less
insulin and this is a very rudimentary
way but you're not gonna put on the kind
of weight your body's gonna run fat
fat instead of glucose when that science
was kind of squashed after World War two
because it was German and remember after
World War two then German German was all
synonymous Nazi yeah so we didn't want
to take their sides we don't want to
take a lot of that stuff so a lot of
Americans written sizes were like [ __ ]
that man we're gonna come up with our
own idea and Ancel keys and a couple of
other people came up with this idea cuz
he did a couple of like shoddy sir
studies would it's called the 7th
continent studies I don't know if you've
heard about it but looked at like people
who were eating what's called what was
considered a low-fat high-fiber diet
like Indian mill workers and stuff and
said they've got really low cholesterol
and all that well they were also eating
very little they were also eating a
certain kind of food and at the end of
the day it was it was not a very good
study but that ushered in the idea that
you eat a high fiber a high carbohydrate
high-fiber low-fat diet and for years
and even now you know that's how people
try to lose weight and the food pyramid
u.s. yeah the US the USDA the
recommended way to lose weight is
they'll tell a woman to eat to have
Special K skim milk a banana and orange
juice and that's how you're supposed
that's your bro your kids lunches
despite your kids lunch we have you seen
maybe your school might be a little
different I have seen but I went to
where my kid goes school there's older
kids and they were doing lunch ago oh
let me just let me see one their lunch
I'm like oh my god what are you doing
I'll sure I'll show you garble yeah and
the thing is as soon as you build up
that glycogen battery like your body's
stored as much you know utilize as much
sugar as you can it just stores the rest
as fat yeah that's my like it's like
you're charging the battery as soon as
it goes over charge I liken it to a
phone like the sugar is like plugging in
your phone but you reach 100% really
fast on sugar like you really don't need
that much more and then the longer you
keep it plugged in the more sugar you
have it just starts building fat like a
giant phone case around your phone and
it's just more storage more storage more
storage and your body just stores that
it fat waiting and hoping for that one
day we do you top that [ __ ] sugar
train and actually get to convert to
ketosis and actually start using the fat
that's on your body
have you found one diet or like because
it's too even but I've done you name a
diet I've probably tried it for me it's
tough to stick the one thing that's in
to make it easy you know I'm saying you
look great shape I'm your own man
what I'd like probably the best I've
seen you yeah and what I've done is what
I talked about in the book which is keto
from morning until dinner and I'll get
my workout in before dinner so like
pretty much all high fat high fiber high
protein before dinners and then I'll
give us an example of what breakfast
would be bone broth avocado I loved
having like some broth because it gets
some extra minerals in there too for
breakfast because you're also even
though I recommend broth never have bone
broth no amazing collagen protein really
high fat you get this big thick layer of
fat on there you can season it up with a
bunch of stuff some avocado I'll make a
smoothie something I don't really pay
you know breakfast is not the most
important meal of the day it's probably
the least important sometimes we'll just
skip it all together and you know do
that you know but yeah I mean generally
a little bit of broth as I'm going out
the door I'm half an avocado and then or
a shake and then for lunch that's where
I just get a much wider variety like a
big ass salad with a bunch of veggies
and weird veggies and protein and fats
and anything I can get and then dinner
you know after I've trained that's what
my glycogen is gonna be at the lowest
and that's also I'll actually hold off I
won't have won't like stuff myself
because a lot of the information that's
out there is for like bodybuilders you
know if you want to hit that anabolic
window I crush a [ __ ] giant giant
smoothie or something easy I'm to work
out if you want to get big but most of
us don't need that and the growth
hormone response will actually be better
if you wait so I'll wait I'll hit my
workout I'll go home I'll have a glass
of wine and like really connect and like
drop in with wit and then that one glass
of wine because my blood volume is lower
you know I'll get a little buzz from
that my liver at that my liver won't
have to filter out all that extra
alcohol so one glass of wine I'm already
feeling loose trying to follow - you
don't say dick games I know and I got
the [ __ ] kid behind me is going dick
games out and it's just below the
[ __ ] frequency well bros you but if
you got what what why he's like I get
home just I should conjuring we're here
a Kinect right I put on a robe I take
one glass of wine striking a little
tipsy I'm again
I didn't know I said that out loud I got
head I was like this in that did come I
mean I'm sorry waiting so the athlete of
the wine of why and then for dinner
although I'll layer in the carbs because
when I have carbohydrate at night I
actually sleep better and there's some
research behind that so like staying in
ketosis is great for mental clarity but
when I do want to shut it off it's not
the best one of the good carbs yeah what
do you eat it's you want slower carbs
right so you want to kill as much of
those really fast like quick starches
that that basically just absorb
immediately so some of the slower carbs
like sweet potatoes are good anything
with a higher fiber and when it's mixed
with fat it all slows down so when it
comes to carbs you just want to slow
down the speed so like processed flour
is gonna be super fast sugar is gonna be
super fast and then grains like quinoa
that you mentioned like some of the
potatoes you're doing like a fish and
like sweet potatoes mashed potatoes and
you know and if you're gonna do bread
one of the best breads a sourdough
because the actual from dough gets
fermented and it breaks down some of
those anti nutrients we talked a bit
about anti nutrients in there that upset
the stomach and to get a nice you know
loaf of sourdough bread rip office bed
butter you're not scared of carbs my mom
I mean you want night that's even even
more of a bro science thing cuz most the
bro science-y listen all my friends are
bro so most of its like if you need
carbs you do it do it during the day so
if we burn them off that night you go no
cards that's what everyone yeah so this
is kind of that carb backloading
approach which is looking at it
differently and so when your
carbohydrates are the lowest you know
because you've been keto all day you've
been fasting all night so you haven't
had carbs for basically 24 hours so
you're on a 24 hour carb fast plus you
crushed a workout and then you layer it
back on replenish yourself and you know
and I'm not going wild you know what I
mean just kind of layering enough so
that my system gets back to full I calm
back down and then I just sleep much
better and I'm held if you worked out in
the morning though if you work out in
the morning then you can still do the
same things you don't need the carbs
immediately or you know the fats and the
proteins and everything else will start
to help your muscles and everything
rebuild I would still push it to the end
though if you really like if you went on
a three-hour uphill
mountain bike ride yeah maybe you give
you one unless you're fully keeping
Aikido converted yeah you know then at
that point you might not need well what
are the supplements you swear by again
all this stuff is in the book yeah
you know honestly man one of the biggest
things you can do is not even worry
about the supplements take the [ __ ]
free doctors here the free doctors
sunlight like we got to get some Sun you
know that's the best way to convert
vitamin D in our body and like all of us
are [ __ ] deficient in vitamin D it's
like there's a reason we feel better
when we're out at the beach you got the
negative ions from the water you got the
Sun in the sky you got you know all of
these things kind of feeding you're
nourishing your body water is another
one exercises a total miracle drug like
no matter what's wrong with you exercise
helps if you're fat if you're depressed
if you're anxious if you want to live
longer like it's a true miracle drug and
you don't have to go to a fancy ass gym
just move and exercise sex is another
miracle drug like ironic pain depression
all of these things that take the
minimum effective dose of these free
things this is from a guy who owns a
supplement company yeah like like look
at that first
yeah and sleep to like sleep people have
all [ __ ] up you know I talked about
that and about ever saying eight
uninterrupted hours of sleep [ __ ]
good luck it's like wishing for a
12-inch dick yeah like it's not gonna
happen to us puts all this [ __ ]
pressure right and then you didn't you
feel bad if you don't get so you're
saying eight hours you don't so another
way to like to last night another yeah
another way to look at it is what this
guy Nick little Hale talks about in his
book sleep he talks about 30 to 35 sleep
cycles a week right in a sleep cycles
about 90 minutes and so you extend it
out through an entire week and naps or a
30-minute nap like a 30-minute what he
calls a controlled recovery paid count
is one point on that so like six hours
would be four sleep cycles if you did
that seven days then that's 28:28 sleep
cycles roughly right and then if you add
it in a couple naps three-four naps
throughout the week then you're at
thirty thirty-two you're right in the
sense where one apps naps naps when when
you look at the research
when you look at the research keep the
longest-lived people they compared more
overnight sleep with more coffee versus
a nap for mental acuity alertness and
how you felt naps win every time let's
[ __ ] smash smash over more overnight
sleep 20 minute nap longest live vehicle
have you ever heard of the coffee nap
where you you consume and I like this
again this might be bro science you've
heard of it
oh you consume coffee they take a
20-minute nap by the time you wake up
the coffee and all this is gonna filter
out so you wake up energized so that's a
problem for people who like if you're
one of those Nappers when you go down
you start [ __ ] droolin rah you're
going into like the super deep sleep
cycle then you might want to do that
because it'll keep you from going to
those deep that's why I say you're
should not be more than 30 minutes right
because if you get in that REM sleep
dark don't you wait 30 minutes like it's
the first 10 minutes you might be
tossing turning and then you'll get that
20 right yeah exactly so I mean what you
really want to do is prevent the really
deep sleep cycles interphase one
interface two interaction wake up right
after REM typically in the sleep cycle
so even though it's at the end and it's
really important it's not the deepest
there's like deeper sleep cycles where
you completely do you get I'm on that
kind of 6 hours if she says you're good
and then and then but I've been napping
and that's been [ __ ] huge I do I have
that little black couch there in the
office and I put that and I put on the
headphones with those binaural beats
that I and it's just really soothing and
it helps you know some brainwave
entrainment there's decent science
behind it but I know what [ __ ] works
for me love you and it's slightly miss
synced beats that create this kind of
pulsing you know it's almost like a
trance you know like if you're going to
war they had that drummer yeah and it
mirrors like kind of the brainwave
states that you want to get to like
theta state or Delta state and it just
kind of helps me relax enough where I'm
not quite asleep but I can feel my face
norm yeah and I can like feel my hands
get really warm and occasionally I'll
get a twitch so it's that
parasympathetic parasympathetic
activation and then when that song is
over I'm off open my eyes get a little
sunlight which then is another signal
for alertness and a weakness if I can
jump on a trampoline kind of move around
a little bit
a trampoline yeah a backyard sure knows
bro yes your notes yeah yeah because
they say like in fighting or anything in
football they'd say you know guys would
get have some so many nerves now I'm I
went too bad but the night before a
fight your nerves are so bad but the
sleep specialist used to always tell the
fighters and all the pros as long as you
sleep that Thursday night before you
sleep catches up with you you know two
days later yeah so if you can't sleep on
Friday you're gonna your body's gonna
perform final on Saturday Sunday I'm you
tired of [ __ ] but Saturday can be good
that's the difference between like maybe
practice and people who are who are just
going by the book and saying oh you need
eight hours and then you talk to someone
like Nick little who work with
Manchester United you talk to someone
who works with actual Navy SEALs who
talk with someone to work with people
like you and they're like yeah actually
not really yeah you know actually you
can catch up yeah and like this is
what's gonna happen if you're actually
kicking ass like this is much more
reasonable protocol my daddy
he hates sleep because he's a workaholic
like me and he's like I'm trying not
sleeping like four hours I'm just gonna
nap throughout the day small naps and
like three days in he was like basically
a zombie my neighbor um
answered the door and he had a he's
looked really down and I and I said
what's up and he goes I lost my job man
I'm you know and I'm really really
scared and worried and he was really
down and I said to Liz oh I know I said
I talked to him about some stuff that
some ideas I like techniques that I you
know have that have worked for me about
it's kind of had a kind of mindset you
know and and he was getting it and then
I said and can I just give you something
I said you should try to work out and
start working out and I swear to God
like I don't care if it's 20 minutes to
but I could tell his body he doesn't do
a lot of that I said I promise you not
only will you feel better but you kind
of be able to think straight
and it was so interesting how he looked
at me like I was a crazy person because
it just it sounded like holding he's
probably 45 and lost his job yeah and I
and I and I was like and he just loved
meet our new intern Terry
he comes to Gary I
I kind of thought meat heart intern
carry on IRA my OD DM me Gary 45 doesn't
know what a podcast is but he's our new
intern ever exercise doesn't exercise
never heard of the difference it's funny
you mentioned your dad was a workaholic
and I you know I have a chapter in there
about work and work efficiency knows
reading and doing some research and in
Japanese culture there's this phenomenon
called Karoshi which is a form of
honorable suicide where you work so hard
that you die at your desk about them
about another day from that is a is a is
a phenomenon in Japan where a nope
a business 45 will just fall down dead
and is oh he was not sleeping ever and
he was working and smoking and drinking
and doing everything could to stay awake
and he just show his commitment to the
company and show us his honor black
where the Korean he's not Japanese no
but even Korean bring it down we've got
incredible rains will work you we need a
Japanese mice don't it might be the
toughest [ __ ] on the planet in
here see what happens unleash his Han
energy on me and then I might die no or
they just create this rivalry and
they're [ __ ] they're trying to
outwork each other and they're here 24/7
they both double ko Jin died Jin died
and that's crazy man yeah yeah I know
Chi Chi Rho XI Chi Roshan I got to do
better that talked to you I talked to
wrote him out a little bit he was always
like dude take Sundays off cuz I did a
Sunday show last night
you always say take Sundays off too so
is Joey Diaz but I booked one it's been
a minute in their name don't you I can
pull it off my pockets was great shoot
my show tomorrow this has been great but
it's a lot man it
a lot but finish your thought on you
were saying about Japanese word I'm work
well it's just a sign that things are
wildly out of balance you know like the
anytime that you get you know workaholic
like we put that on a pedestal but again
that's a sign that something internally
is off
like that's not a day you want to repeat
over and over again is a day where all
you do is work and I think that's a big
message of this things like you want to
live a life because all there is is the
days of your life like there's no end
point the no [ __ ] goal you're working
towards and not this thing there's just
the process all the way through and when
you get way out of balance then things
like that happen and you see these
phenomenons like they're clearly not
taking enough time to really enjoy their
family enjoy sex
Joyce food enjoy like laughter enjoy
playing music enjoy doing whatever it is
that makes us actually human and they've
become this kind of robotic work machine
type of mentality as if they're doing it
for honor or doing it for some other
purpose but I think the biggest problem
is that nobody even knows why they're
doing it I think people are so
disoriented exactly trying to find
meaning or purpose or even community is
impossible it's it's it's something has
happened where and you know you hear
people use the word consumerism and
stuff like that about them you know you
hear that I think there's a lot of truth
to that I think uh efficiency abundance
yes yes Walmart does save the average
family something like twenty five
hundred dollars a year okay - at what
cost
what if what if you love your work
though you know some people love to work
or live to work right you know it's just
that's [ __ ] great and enjoy that you
know but also like take a look and see
and make sure that you're not missing
the other make sure that you're not
missing the other things that you really
enjoy because typically when I'm the
most enthusiastic about my life overall
it's not the amount of time that I'm
working I just do everything better
you know I'm inspired when I do it after
I have a great night out with wood or a
great night with my friends or I connect
with somebody over lunch then I leave
and I'm triple the human being that I
was before better work yeah you know and
a lot of people like oh I can't go
floating I don't have the
time I'm like trust me man go floating
and you'll come back and you'll be like
[ __ ] Batman find another six hours
afterwards because you'll have so much
and like the float tank I do I like the
flow tank I like the naps I like
ecstatic dance although I love yoga the
float tanks we tried it in San Francisco
damn it that you jerked off and then I
thought everybody has except for me I
was laying in a [ __ ] yes in a [ __ ]
assault [ __ ] soup I've never got never
going to one of those progress I don't
know it was nice I don't know it was
nice I'm not crazy around like you and
Rogan I don't know maybe I should need
to do it more it's just a great way
where you literally have nothing to do
like you have to run shut your brain up
I think in this book is what I got from
the book also is that being healthy is
actually not that hard no I mean it's
not it's it's not it sounds like like
you're done they can be hard there's a
lot of steps but you can get to a point
where being healthy is actually more
about what you don't do versus what you
do do and it's just it's really small
choices yeah like it's little star very
small a conscious choice like not one
thing in there is hard I'm not saying
you have to go run this mountain I'm not
saying you have to go fast for this
amount of time or do anything every
little thing is okay wake up put a
little sea salt in your water have a
little splash of them and drink that
first that's not hard get a little
sunlight set your circadian rhythm
that's not hard get a little movement
walk around with your dog do some
push-ups whatever that's not hard every
single step along the way take the
shower nozzle from hot to cold just turn
it and just get a little cold water on
your body that's gonna increase
norepinephrine that's gonna drop your
chronic stress it's gonna drop your
anxiety to do that it's gonna release
adrenaline if you hold your breath is
one of the practices in there that's not
hard either and then all of a sudden all
these winds start to accumulate what's
hard is looking at here I am fat
unhealthy unhappy and I got to get to
their superhuman super happy super I'll
climb in
yeah and it makes over well to how you
eat and what your gut is doing they're
finding more more you know is has a lot
to do with like your mental state it can
actually cause de prov dude when I'm
stressed it's off the hinges I mean
you're if I'm low on sleep yeah okay and
I have this meal company now when I'm on
the road it's tough but on the road it
happens cuz you do not get a lot of
sleep you're going from neck see neck
city and there's like [ __ ] ice need
calories I need to eat something make
that decision yeah yeah and and no to
that it's not black or white we have
this start fresh Monday we have like if
you're halfway through the chocolate
cake and you push it away that's a
[ __ ] win like take that w you know if
you're eating the doughnut and you leave
a bite for the gods and throw that pit
that that's a win I call it winning but
yeah but like take any little any little
win and like working out go home for a
walk like doing a little something that
counts like every little bit for
mentally count yeah I think I think
learning how to talk to yourself at 51
now like I think if there's anything I
would say there's younger people it's
always like learn how to talk to
yourself in a positive way because it's
really easy to talk to yourself in a
shitty way cuz you know I don't know
that we're all I don't know that we even
wired or evolved to like ourselves that
much and there is there is a lot of
benefit maybe and sort of like expected
so you can hope for the worst or prepare
for that you can hope for the best or
prepare for the worst
sometimes preparing for the worst in
life is not a bad thing I think if you
do be hard on yourself it is but you
know anyone who's killing just like
yourself is one thing but learning how
to talk to yourself in a positive way so
that it spurs you to further action to
continue to grow but we do a lot of
times we go I'm a piece of [ __ ] I failed
I saw can we see it because then you
think you deserve to suck and that's I
think deserving that's you know that's
the final thing that I close with is if
you keep telling yourself a piece of
[ __ ] we have this internal justice
system where we're doling out rewards
and punishment and if you keep telling
yourself of a peak you're a piece of
[ __ ]
then you're gonna deserve what a piece
of [ __ ] deserves correct but if you say
man I got a long way to go but I'm
[ __ ] hustling I'm tryin then you'll
feel like man I deserved that's that's
where the haters come from that's that's
where I like on the Internet
time's the you know if you get a hit or
trow something like that every now and
then I'll go dude what are you doing man
don't be a troll switch if they have a
kid oh you have a son man you don't want
to be that guy and they'll usually spawn
back dude sorry man my life sucks I want
to try stand-up I see you doing I'm like
I have nothing to do with your happiness
man it's not me you're mad at me cuz
you're not taking the risk just go do it
man
one of the things one of most profound
things I you know I never spent any time
in therapy but I was an acting class for
I don't know let's call it 13 years know
when you're in third Bureau oh my god
and an acting teacher on the level that
I had some of the best in the world
they've been doing it for 30 40 years so
they they are masters at psychology and
they're masters at reading human
behavior and and one of the things that
I had an acting teacher say to me which
was I never forgot I said man I'll tell
you what's really hard for people is to
allow themselves but give themselves
permission to even have to own anything
to have to think to themselves maybe I
deserve like this is a huge one just to
say to yourself you know maybe I deserve
a little something for myself
some Hayek lectured my friend who's an
actress and she said sama said is that
when she was killing it she goes you
have to start telling yourself that you
deserve something cuz you're not saying
that to yourself and then she goes my
biggest secret is that I had a long time
ago as I said why not me why don't I
deserve it you can get a little high T
Tauri with this [ __ ] but I have a
problem that because I like I deserve to
eat this donut I deserved by these Gucci
booths
I deserve this poor something do that
though because I did kind of like you're
valuing yourself yeah you know when you
buy yourself a gift and I've seen you do
it yeah like you know you have a lot of
self-esteem there's certain there's a
certain pride to saying you know what
I'm gonna look good I'm gonna try to
look good I'm gonna dress well that's a
big step like when you buy a car with
leather seats it's funny you say this
because my acting teacher used to
[ __ ] say it he'd go you getting a car
huh why are you driving that piece of
[ __ ] why don't you buy a car with
leather seats well I can't afford it
figure it out decide that you can it
sounds like we're careful now
get yourself broke but there is a
mindset there is something there is
something of value to say you know what
I feel good well in this car I feel like
I bought I did something nice to myself
I did I celebrated something no doubt
and I think there is that fine line
between entitlement feeling like you
deserve it even though you're not yeah
like that hater you mentioned we're like
I deserve to be up there on stage but
they're not doing the work yeah you know
like all you can really ever take
ownership of is the process like the
outcome of your success is not within
your control
but like did you do the things did you
like I said at the start like did you
pay the blood price like I had a million
chances to turn this over to an editor
and like not read it and there was times
I showed it was like there was literally
a naked pool party going on at my house
with the girls and they were drinking
wine and I had a deadline and I just
watched the whole day go by every once
in a while and just [ __ ] worked on
the book really look jack sorry Aubrey
he that moment was like I had a choice
like I could have easily said alright
editors you guys figure this out I don't
need to reread this book as my sixth
time I was like no I got a Snoop Dogg
video yeah like the universe was tested
and then now now when I give this book
to people I can like look him in the eye
and say yeah it's the best [ __ ] book
I could do and I was tested you know
like I had the opportunity to not do
that but I didn't I think it's I be I
think a lot of people won't write a book
or won't do this we won't try this or
won't start a podcast or whatever name
it whatever they want to do because
they're scared to fail you know I'm
saying they're super scared to fail
because that's their biggest fair like I
this gentleman that maybe Tampa may was
Orlando he goes dude all my friends tell
me I should do stand-up and I'm the same
age as you and I see you doing it I went
to one open mic and it's just hold my
froze and got first time yeah yes it's
the first time so that's pretty normal
but then I was the actual year's tonight
this just remind me the Garry Shandling
champion Garry Shandling documentary on
HBO that Judd Apatow did but they posted
Garry Shandling had a diary that he'd
write in he'd go to
be rewriting these things and he hated
himself but he's talking about how his
process and how he would he would have
so much stage fright this is Garry
Shandling with the greatest of all time
Mount Rushmore right and he would write
on there how you have all the states
right and all these negative thoughts
but if he prepared right he deserved it
you know I'm saying like yeah and the
reason why he this he was scared to get
on stage is cuz he was worried what
people are gonna say or think about him
all the time yeah he's always scared
that what if this what if this what if
this and they see he draws the line
underneath his genitals forget that man
if I put in the work it's gonna go good
who cares what they do and it goes out
to piggy but it's the same thing with
that kid I I told him I said he goes
what you do for your first one and I
said my situation has been different
meaning that when my first time did
stand-up I had Bryan Callen had Chris
D'Elia Joe Rogan on the front row but by
the time I did that set I've done it I
don't know five hundred times in my
bathroom so I know it might it it's not
gonna it's not give me on a special
Netflix but for what that time for
hearse I was I knew even if I was
nervous as [ __ ] did what she was at
least gonna be the five minutes that I
was supposed to go you could lean back
on the process I know like I know I know
I don't have to like them I said I'm
doing now if there was a gun going off
if someone release doves if these people
are talking if this dudes jacking off in
the corner whatever if there's I can get
through this set because I've rehearsed
it so many times I'm so discipline on
that stuff won't bother me and it goes
back to what you were saying when you
when you're afraid of failure well it
goes back to the process it's like what
what is what are you trying to
accomplish
you know just the doing of it just the
just taking action and and learning
something and by the way there is no
such thing as doing anything in the
beginning when you don't suck everything
you're gonna suckle is that's not even
the point the point is you took action
the point is you're in the process of
doing something and the doing of it and
the reach is there again I think we all
would agree at least I would agree I
would say that I don't think there is
any such thing as getting there I don't
even believe in celebrities no there
I don't I don't think there's any I
don't there's there's I'm a successful
guy if people come up to me and say
you're you know bah bah bah bah it's all
right wait I don't feel successful at
all I got a lot more work to do it I'm
just all relative it's all relative
so failure what are you trying to
accomplish I would say but I know why
you'd be scaring scared of water of your
friend like you get defined by people
right so weird to me like like my sewing
I get this question all the time we go
man would you rather be the heavyweight
champion of the UFC or have a comic
special and I'm I can say this full
heart of this again economy special
would be my my end-all be-all in these
like what aren't you worried what people
would say if it airs Mike what do I care
man did I'm not I don't you cares what
people would say I mean who would make I
don't I don't I don't know you don't
define you something if the special
[ __ ] suck yeah bro gimmick Glee and
you guys might make fun of me not being
I make fun of me for in the process of
trying to die cause you did everything
you could to try to like express
yourself for an hour the hardest thing
in the world and you did it like this
nosy newbie should it's a book sucks
balls yeah I read the book because RB
III all I had you know why I read the
book right away it had nothing to do
with I've read a lot of these books I've
I've I've been following nutrition all
that but the weight you go you said
something in a note which was hey this
is the best I can do I like the lead
blood I know this is my blood 'no sand i
went this [ __ ] put everything
into it that's an effort
I really appreciate effort thank you
brother you know and and so of course I
was gonna read it and that's when people
ask me about the expectations about it
like it takes so much of the pressure
off because I know that I've done
everything could and you can just really
rely on that just doing your best is all
you can do and having that background
like people look at Conor McGregor right
he has this amazing belief when he goes
in the ring he's giving us the secret to
his belief all the time what'd he say
all the time hard work hard work he said
to us in the pot [ __ ] hard work
because he and whether this is true or
not but he believes he works harder than
everybody out there and I'm sure he
works he was different you know he works
hard or he worked smarter and so he he
knows that he's done everything that he
could in his mind to make him the best
Conor McGregor possible so he can go in
there all [ __ ] million
Luce and other people are like did I do
everything I know I don't know if I did
everything I could and he's like I did
everything I could [ __ ] okay
yeah exactly and that's and that's all
you can do is is win those little
battles know that you laid it out there
and [ __ ] if you get slain if this book
gets [ __ ] shredded and it doesn't you
know doesn't do any good like I'm going
out on my shield so what do you say will
be the shield's on New York let's just
take times like there are a lot of days
where you just don't feel like doing
[ __ ] right yeah so how do you talk to
yourself the thing that's been great is
the small little battle in the morning
with the shower nozzle cuz I always take
a shower in the morning or if it's now
I've been swimming laps but but winning
versus comfort versus the cold cuz I
know for a hundred percent certainty the
cold makes me feel better helps my body
it helps my mind
I love helps everything so if I can just
no matter how shitty I feel no matter
how down I feel is I I do vary a lot I'm
not like supercharged every day but when
I win that first battle I'm like okay
I'm stronger than this [ __ ] I'm stronger
than my urge drop another one these two
it does man it does and that these
little tiny little tiny wins you know
when I want to listen to some you know
shitty music and instead I put on a
funny podcast where I know I'm gonna
laugh even if I don't feel like I
deserve to laugh I'll put that thing on
it'll be like all right you know this is
the small little victory so I'd shrink I
shrink the sample size like that's I
think the key to getting out of any one
little one little little maybe things a
step in the right direction yeah I
couldn't agree more like just just one
tiny thing even if it's five minutes
start with that like go swing a
kettlebell for literally five minutes
you know whatever it might be well you
know I did the other day then I'm glad
you brought this up the other day I
pulled up to the gym and I sat in my car
and then I just left but you have no
problem with discipline rock no I'm sure
someday no one might know and I was just
I haven't had a day off and on how long
I got to the gym I could do every
morning smile routine and I was like god
man I'm sick of this [ __ ] meaning like I
just need to switch it up I need I think
something that's gonna challenge me like
it if it's not challenging me I'm going
through the motions I don't like to try
legit sewer
I've been working out since what fifth
grade yeah I take somebody [ __ ] maybe
you needed a break actually you know I
already got there I looked around like
no one's even you know what I think you
know what I think you should do went to
the Jimmy firaon I'm being dead serious
and I've said this to you a long time
ago I I couldn't be more serious than
the right level of time yep aye aye I
think you say bailing I think you should
be this is gonna sound crazy I think
she'd be taking singing and dance
lessons I take so much time y'all worked
out in the morning I gotta give up
everything feelin ya again I'm gonna say
again I know I understand I hear you
100% it couldn't be more busy I think
you should be taking singing and I think
and I I don't think I know in one year
the difference in everything it's
performance wise and even writing wise
will be maybe that's just me yeah I
don't know anything do get a YouTube you
know like just like do some basic [ __ ]
you know I have no problem doing that I
don't know I find the time commit to
that I'm just saying as far as you get
any comments just give like if our like
I have to get something to get my body
so yeah but like that's why I'm here
yeah I'm down for that I'm saying as far
as like boxing doesn't I've been doing
forever like lifting weights certainly I
do I've been doing it forever like women
oh yeah it take somebody clapping he was
in the NFL me and him Pop Warner
football together attacked and he's a
bit most big strong as you've seen Cobb
he's the absolute superhero superhero
like Thor if there's a real-life Thor
it's him yeah for a knight rock look I
text yeah the rock like Jesus so I text
only go hey me never get to the gym and
just like [ __ ] this he goes dude I
haven't worked out in four months yeah
work out since fifth grade man that's it
well you need now if I miss it because
your condition of that it when I miss
I'm like oh my god what did I do
yeah I think just just varying it up go
outside go for like and that's that's
part of the issue of being out here but
like go for a little beach run like I'll
do something hike do something weird you
know like get out of like really it
doesn't it doesn't matter
exactly what you do as long as you're
doing something like as long as you're
getting that minimum effective ability
like I've been swimming way more and
sometimes that'll be the only thing I'll
do in the day it's just hit 30 40 laps
in my little pool and it's a great
workout and then that's and it doesn't
even really feel like a workout I'm
getting cold I'm getting movement and
then if I workout again later
bonus bone rate you know no I did I get
with those peloton bikes I lived it
literally gets delivered
Wednesday nice I've never even been on
one I was like man if you know cuz but
like days today tomorrow when I shoot I
might call time that 7 a.m. so if I
would get I can't get to the gym Jim's
not open that early so I figure I just
go downstairs knock out that class maybe
wake me up and then go for the record a
voice class would take you one day a
week and in the rescue woods that you
would do it in your car and you would
just work on your voice in the car with
vocal exercises and then you would sing
a song ok so for the record as you're
driving you would do that for a half
hour a day okay and as far as dance is
concerned and I'll do it with you I can
do and I'll do it with you like and and
all that - it's the class will you will
and that would be maybe twice a week and
the rest of his practice there's no way
there isn't you can do it I think you
know once you're in it you're in this
unique spot where you have such a base
and like you're so far down the line
like probably most of the people
listening are just trying to get that
first [ __ ] movement don't sign up
singing less of any sort that first
learn how to play learn how to play for
10 songs on the guitar it's remarkably
easy
my son's taken guitar was like that down
to like one chord you know like me my
first instrument was this flute and I
was terrible at it and I just eventually
used string a couple notes and played
the flute bring up pan please he played
the flute with his huge rock in the
forest half goat it's how he would bring
Seder a seder thank you sir
yes how he would bring women and keep
going with the flute please sir
definitely wasn't one of those long
hauls with all the look at his [ __ ] take
one [ __ ] it's constantly hard you
haven't seen pan far as God no he's got
a dick on him bro
always had a dick he's got a
hindquarters I played that guy with the
[ __ ] Robin Hood seen him in the
forest I'd be like [ __ ] yeah are you
gonna wear my face is mask exactly yeah
there's a I got to meet marcus luttrell
which was dope and he he told me God
cast with him yeah you guys are yeah he
has his podcast with the frogman guy
yeah so his partner David rather up to
you so he came to my show in Palm Beach
and this is funny because I haven't seen
him since I didn't know who they this
consign bad I didn't know who they were
I didn't know David luttrell was the
lone survivor guy they're nice luttrell
marcus luttrell yeah David luttrell was
a football player but they they're there
do you see like yeah he looks normally
so um so he big boy
they don't like traumatized at all so
the thing is is uh they wanted me to
this podcast in Thule X you know Lex
McMann and they asked me to do it and
I'm so busy man and I kind of blew him
off I'll do it and then I haven't seen
or talked to him since um and they came
to the show and like said go meet my
friends like these are the Navy SEALs
you blew off oh [ __ ]
but anyways great dude yeah David
David's great Marcus is great but that
story he tells about and it was in the
movie I think survivor lone survivor
when he's all shot up and all of his
friends have died and he's throwing
himself off multiple cliffs and he's
just broken everywhere and he has to
crawl out you know like an unimaginable
amount of distance on his elbows and
like the process that he went through to
do that he literally pushed his arm as
far out as he could in the dirt and drew
a line in the dirt and then he said all
I got to do is cross that line and he
crawled his broken ass wounded body
bleeding to that line and then he
stretched his arm out again and he made
another line he crawled it and he
crawled his way through there like
that's that's what we have to do like if
he can do that even then he was he knew
as a Navy SEAL one of the toughest men
in the world he would quit if he thought
about that he had to go a mile
but if all he had to think about was oh
man I just got to get these two feet
where I drew this line I can do that I
just got to get these next two feet he
didn't like organic to that house you
know just like this little thing the
movies did you have him on your podcast
I went on their podcast the team never
quit part yeah team never quit out of
this ranch we shot some shadows fun
shooting guns with Navy SEALs is they're
badasses but a language for them yeah
it's awesome yeah they were throwing
[ __ ] in the pond and we were blasting it
it's such a crazy story man yeah that's
crazy but that's it you know just just
that one next little [ __ ] thing you
know the book that's all--that's we
started with the book yeah the next
little [ __ ] thing I think a lot of
times you know I wrestle with the idea
defining myself in a certain way and
I've tried to write a script many many
times so after a while you go I'm not a
writer and it's really easy to fall into
that you know and then you talk to
writers and they go oh you're just doing
it wrong you know try this and then you
get a little closer to it but it's
really hard to not define yourself you
know especially as you get older and
especially as people know you as a
certain thing sometimes the people that
are around you are really good at
defining you and keeping you within
certain yeah you got to give up all that
[ __ ] you got to surrender all your claim
to who you think you are and just be
like I am I [ __ ] am and I'm gonna do
stuff and I'm gonna do stuff I am and
I'm gonna do stuff like that's all I'm
gonna be bad in the beginning yeah in
the beginning it may be bad at it
I love Rogen's think conquer your inner
[ __ ] yeah I've always liked that
because you know I'm gonna be bad at it
but you Rogen's secret I'll tell you a
secret right now all Rogan does is this
he goes all right I want to be good at
archery or I want to be good at running
or I want to be good at jiu-jitsu I'm
gonna show up every day I'm gonna suck I
know I'm gonna suck for the first year
maybe four months I don't what it is I'm
gonna suck but the difference between
everybody else at me is I'll be there
every day maybe it'll be a half hour
might be an hour but I'll be there every
day just consistency and you just get
better yeah you don't identify with any
of the external things you're not an
archer right off about of course you're
not an archer you're not a comic before
you've ever gone onstage you're not any
of these things that you want to be you
you are and you do stuff that's it it's
like it's super simple you give up the
rest just give it all away somebody
somebody pushed something on you oh
thanks for that compliment thanks for
calling me this day you're talking about
play shieler my favor
things Schiller said man is never more
himself than when at play and plays not
hookers and speedball play is the thing
you do for the sake of its own doing
like the thing you do for free anyway
there's something [ __ ] really fun
about getting good at something you know
even if it's tiny little increments
every day mmm so let's begin good Qin
yet some current events
corinna fans bring in a Japanese man so
you get some battle it out no okay don't
beat the [ __ ] out of it jack you hate
Japanese people chen i don't hate on hey
is it racism if i calm
yes is it racist name for koreans oh
yeah i was used caps as a term that was
used in World War two well there are
enemies yes a Japanese Japanese right
yeah Jews isn't offensive right now if
you're a Jew that's fine depends if no
I'm just saying but you could say Jew
yeah yeah if you were to say are you a
Jew it depends of how you say but you
can't Japanese crowd upon yeah hey Jim
you're I'm a Jew I'm Jewish I get it and
I'm just saying but when you say he's a
Jew it there's been so much anti-semite
I know has used that was all in tongue
what do you mean you know yeah anytime
you separate somebody like he's a
cracker
he's a cracker honky ass cracker town
cracker [ __ ] cracker doesn't
bother me
you know what cracker stems from you
know what Sims from cracker it's not
because we're white like crackers the
black people call crackers they call
that the slave owners because they've
come crackers when they'd slap on with
the whip it cracked they come cracker
differenti other brain [ __ ] box a
great different book club did she do
different definition for it look at
Cocker yeah that's what I've heard
yeah I heard something Dave called
crackers now from the Nebraska I think
it's a little bit different I think
that's right I think you're gonna find a
different reason for it let's take a
look
cracking I think you're gonna need to
use it as a slur search as a slur all
the secret has to you the word cracker
go
that's alright yeah yeah I guess no no
go back
that's like I love rich grand urban
dictionary I would go back I'd go back
first I'd go back one more and then go
down to the secret history of the word
cracker this one right here just on yeah
urban dictionaries hillarious cuz you
can google anybody's name and it's
something horrible I think it actually
was somebody's name I don't think there
was the cracking from the web's on the
slaves crack sense but I heard a
different thing poor whites so poor
white people couldn't afford food that's
why it is suspected that it was a
shortened version of whip cracker since
the manual labor they did involve
driving livestock with a whip mm-hmm
it's the whipping of the crack was a
huge yeah it was it was it had to do
with the people from the South who had
come from Ulster in the north of England
I know that I'm a further yeah oh yeah
it goes back to the 17th century so this
is an English thing the mirror word has
changed a lot over the last four
centuries a Florida historian
anthropology studies crackers yeah
there's a book written called cracker
actually it's a book called cracker it
doesn't land though to your point
Brandon I don't think that I don't think
anybody ever gets that stress because we
don't even know what the [ __ ] it means
that there's like no bad word for white
people I mean is it because it's just
full carbs if you're white male no
you're not white male you're Spanish so
get away from me hey you I shaving me
laughter video I sent Julian count a
video of me cuz they make for me they
call me a road bump Road Dogg [ __ ] man
I've been driving all over yeah
alligator alley by myself I know 600
miles you're doing well you're I'm not
giving you your [ __ ] black pot yet no
I don't want a black belt well well but
I mean that's what a road dog gets
alright and definitely not black but you
get you know you big you bigger puppy um
you know what what we wrote down no no
no I know I'm like a hound dog I'm not
giving you that you're ain't nothing but
ain't nothing but a hound Drive
alligator how are you driving you're out
there on E
I was on E you're out there you're out
there and I'm happy I'm proudly shows
hot there's a lot of shows all right
Sunday to putting in your bones Rhode
Island no don't say that now no I'm
talking about when you shave because I
base all I said I said Brian and delete
a video of me like listen some Drake
music and I was driving in the car
headed wherever I went I went Road dog
Road dog and then Brian goes
they don't even comment on the video
brightness bro you know your Spanish
right because I didn't shave I like this
thick like black beard I looked down
like I look 100% Puerto Rican right now
I've never said I could not it was the
first thing I did I checked into it
straight to the [ __ ] mayor and shaved
man look so the span it looked like the
guy from the cartoon I was like I don't
know I look at the copycat Brown pride
tattoos you know I like that yeah I like
badness fresh off the boat
got out of Cuba I grew out the Jew beard
recently pretty big beard yeah we sent
ourselves crazy [ __ ] he just woke up hi
Jim
no down though that's all we do send
videos back and forth Rogan doesn't
really Rogan doesn't really like that I
could try to get him involved in our
thing and he just can't do it never whoa
she's another teacher look at how hot
she acts Kendall with a 13 year old boy
and she is pretty hot can we celebrate
on the right they have the right mix up
some 30 Oguz dick sucked by the smokes
oh my god why would she do that to a 13
year old she's so hot dog 27 year old I
guess have you seen a 30 no lately it's
on the street yeah especially men give
me but I remember balling back in the
day some 13 yards can dunk
yeah if you can dunk you should probably
dude why are these teacher so hot doing
this it's crazy how would what city is
this chin and where she was like in why
was her bail she's she's hot she
delicious [ __ ] for oral sex I'm just
saying the way her mother do that that
mouth yeah what that mouth do girl I
mean I'm so in the classroom she did she
did it or sucked it in in a classroom
dude
this is every 13 year-olds fantasy true
what do you think that what you think
causes that Brian psychology behind it a
psychology man I think you fall in love
with somebody you're around all the time
there's one kid who seems older she's a
little kid too though she's 27
she's a full-grown adult I don't know
man that's one of the ones it's hard
there are some that are attracted to
children but like that is like abuse and
cycles that have gone and like but this
one is this one is a weird one yeah you
don't have a picture of the kid no they
wouldn't happen we always think of it as
a man on a child on a boy or a girl
right now see if this was if this was a
man on him he wouldn't I would freak the
[ __ ] out and you'd there'd be no jokes
that's right yeah because it's this
smoke show and suck in I was 13 I was 15
I mean my teacher she had cancer of the
nose she lost her nose I would let her
suck a dick
yes little lo mismo [ __ ] only reason I
bring light to it's because I was 13 I
was in those shoes if someone off suck
my dick I would do it yeah I probably
talked
and had it done when I was 13 a and
eight hundreds too much [ __ ] my teachers
knows and she had a whole new system
this is where I know yeah but you
apologize mrs. roach she's dead right
she passed away
Roach great cancer you can't let her
rest in peace it's a it's I didn't think
it's the problem with anything that's
like a fixed rule you know like every
thirteen means a billion different
things maybe this kid maybe he did get
taken advantage of maybe he was really
young and immature we're making
assumptions that he's the dude the dunks
and he's like got his [ __ ] together and
we've met that guy I've also met 13 year
olds that are shy and timid and maybe
she took advantage maybe that's it is
super [ __ ] up but like the law is not
gonna give you any any lead way she's
gonna serve hard ass time maybe she
deserves it if she was predatory maybe
she doesn't yes we did you eat one of
the greatest books ever written
Nabokov's Lolita sure it's it's it's
everybody should read it everybody
should listen to Jeremy Irons narrated
on audible.com but here's the thing
about it that [ __ ] is mind-blowing
this is in the 50s
Nabokov wrote a book about a pedophile
who was into girls little girls I think
there were nine ten nine to twelve was
his age range and he makes a distinction
between nine and ten to eleven twelve
year old girls and then he calls certain
women some certain girls nymphets and
nymphets are a different kind of
creature now all of us go you're a
pedophile what Nabokov did which he sets
a genius is he takes a pedophile who
falls in love and has an affair with a I
think a 12 year old something 11 he yes
she's 12 I think he makes him a
sympathetic character and Juliana's you
know and you you yeah you go you you in
the movie with Peter Sellers and in the
book no matter where you stand on it you
go you feel horrifyingly bad for the
main character and that is how it goes
though like with an arc those two
because I gotta go Oh best markets away
then a moms terrible perfume Silence of
the Lambs you make him feel fast lambs
you feel bad to win he eats people and
you're like I'm rooting for the cat
watch out chop with
like what I think that's why when you
look at like the Norwegian prison system
that looks to humanize the inmates and
likes recognize the human in all of us
and try to rehabilitate the good instead
of just that purely punitive action
there's a lot to kind of learn from that
because there's some there's some
horrible [ __ ] out there and there should
be consequences absolutely and it [ __ ]
man especially with the sexual abuse oh
it's so [ __ ] common like so many
people I know that you'd been like I
didn't even realize it tell us 34 and
I'm like in all kinds of we'd like to
destroy people though like you make one
mistake all your screws you dance on the
edge some people are just dancing on the
edge of some kind of inappropriate
behavior of whatever it might be whether
it's sexual or whatever and nowadays I
always say this with social media you're
destroyed people are have no problem
just destroying ruin your crew it's a
capital offense because it's a form of
assassination thank you so much you did
that and you'll never work again you'll
never have a job again right give like
give people a chance to make up for it
by recognizing their humanness and give
something positive back it's the only
you can't undo the I have you have you
seen the Netflix documentary called I'm
a pause for emphasis called push okay
there's about wise yeah no it's it's
where they get it's where they get a
random person to add to a point where
they actually push somebody off a roof
and commit murder and it is one of the
[ __ ] realities oh it's a very old
documentary and this guy who's been
doing TV shows for a long time play the
trailer educator police is the push is
the right one it's called a push better
there it is play that for a second it
saw last night it blew my [ __ ] don't
no spoilers it's completely
- Lucas stages the wet eyes and that
it's not oughtn't I needed a player like
there's only one way out when he's told
to commit murder my name is Darren brown
and the question we're considering is
simple can we be manipulated through
social pressure to commit murder welcome
you to the post this was one of the more
mind-blowing human examples of how you
give up ownership of your life and and
it's funny because your thing is called
own the day and it is there are there's
a subset of the population it's a large
one and it's a social experiment and you
give up authorship a logic you said it's
good that let's say I'm endorsing it
I can feel a breeze live hey - you know
it's hot it's one of the best things
I've ever seen
I'm gonna watch it I saw last night and
you're gonna come back and you're gonna
go hole I bet it's understand that it's
it's it's literally so mind-blowing
I watched it my wife told me to watch it
on the same way I'm always I got fog
that trail look so it's 70 actors around
one dude and you go you watch it and
you're seeing some mob mentality though
it's not just that it's you can get
somebody in a position of such high
pressure that they feel like the only
way out and it's a certain type of
person yes that's what I do certain time
you show me a picture young there's a
lot of pressure on them to perform
they're trying to do good first thing
first thing is in their mind in this
thing they're trying to do something
very good for us I think that's a key
thing because I think a lot of the
people who do bad stuff they justify it
in some way where they think it's good
or the other person deserved it or
there's very few like truly like evil
demonic people know they're doing
something wrong right and still do it
anyways most people just justify its
kind of jordan Peterson's argument about
how anybody could be a Nazi prison guard
in the right circumstances you convince
yourself enough that you're doing such a
USANA problem
yeah yeah what else you got chin that
looks terrible Brent but I'll walk it's
not no I'm not saying is I'm saying that
trailer made me go
[ __ ] you'll be like oh really god oh
dude it's how long on us is in my power
it's like I have 72 minutes maybe I'll
watch it tonight yeah
what is she all right the next one is
mad Mike Hughes he actually launched his
rocket over the weekend oh [ __ ] you got
a flat this guy Bobby no I'm no nor
should you nor should you here on the
final kid we've been falling this guy's
every move he's create a go fund me to
launch his own sky rock he's the one
who's gonna see if to say that's the
earth is flat he wants to launch himself
up there to prove to everyone the earth
is flat yeah he did it he launched
himself up but he didn't get that I went
to 1,800 feet [ __ ] top 1870
Southwest flight mm that's actually over
a mile right what is a mile 5,200 feet
miles miles 52 I'm sorry those kids are
on there too what a complete waste of
time
gutsy [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] yeah there it
goes well yeah in that he was in it you
don't see actually looks like it goes
pretty high she's pretty smart to
obviously build the rock and do all this
see that and then it just goes up to
there
dude that that [ __ ] a human cannonball
does he pull chute here I guess I had to
pull it twice cuz the first one didn't
slow it down enough and then he did mess
up his back on the way down
so that's the first year I know what you
get well there's uh some faulty logic
going in on those did you really think
you were able to prove there this earth
is flat follow these guys all the
scientists are wrong with this guy's
right I bet he came back with a [ __ ]
deftly flat the narrative is great when
everybody's all big farmers bad all of
it all all Sciences bet well I'm the one
it's a grandia's personality I'm the one
who's you're the one that found it
it's a superiority game right because if
you believe something that everybody
else doesn't then you're somehow
superior it's really goes favorite in
traffic
I knew it everybody else is [ __ ] my
life may suck and whatever but I know
this and everybody doesn't so they're
all shields and I'm the man also the
sunlight daylight the rotation of Earth
with the Sun if it was flat it'd just be
daylight all the goddamn time it makes
no sense think about it I didn't miss
fourth grade what else you got yeah this
is kind of creepy a Chicago cop so
there's a guy that was apparently saying
he want to commit suicide so this cop
and another cop drove him to the
hospital to just you know get his head
checked out and then the guy was
actually strapped chained to the bed and
this cop ended up fondling his all he's
a freak
yeah he still got that turtleneck this
is amazing we are human beings are so
interesting cops sucked suicidal man's
toes and sexually assaulted him at
hospitals go to the bathroom
trivia what is it called when you suck
somebody's toes sex place got it
something about podiatry shrimping no no
yesterday yes yesterday we go on
shrimping girls get shrimping bro you
could you're so just ripping it's stuck
on this cowboy no not my thing
yeah I think I'm not opposed [ __ ] as
it is definitely an escalator especially
if the especially if they don't expect
it you get that whole I said and they're
like oh damn he's on another little I
don't give a [ __ ] this dude's a freak
yeah I know a girl tell me her boyfriend
this guy she's to have sex with he would
take her foot and stick it in his mouth
while he was railing and I was like oh
[ __ ] I gotta do that now but I never did
it's a [ __ ] interesting move well
they know that it's game on it's game
later it might feel bad for the girls if
you've seen my big toe yeah I think
there's always some part it's like Fred
Flintstone like so
like oh my girl has like a little bitty
so that's about like oh how do I taste
like what do I look like you [ __ ]
take that foot it's all jamming in your
throat and they're like he loves all of
me oh so I take a [ __ ] in the face no I
have it but you know what I did do I saw
in a Kama Sutra book there's this
position called the herd of cows can you
bring this up herd of cows kamasutra and
I managed to with the help of Caitlin I
managed to create this fantasy called
the herd of cows where you have all of
your your feet out and your thumbs out
and you have somebody riding your toes
and your thumbs I need to visualize this
the balls that's not it
they've got so they've got there so
basically how many how many people does
this take five and then there's people
on your toes there's people on your
thumbs and then there's someone riding
you've had five women do then I did one
you talked in that's impressive as hell
I was younger I was like my young 30s
[Music]
called a herd of cows laughter I'll have
to send you the venue the image but
that's the I actually never had anybody
suck my toes but I did I feeling a big
toe I feel like you feel nice I think I
think it would probably I mean it's like
it's a limpid shrimp in a Nizam agile
sense there it is possibly that's okay
that's what she did
yeah God talked about sex when I think
of a herd of cows I think of a herd of
cows let the fat girls lined up and then
I'm just behind crackin I'm a cowboy the
funny thing about like the multiple you
know cuz I've been fortunate I've been
super blessed and like threesomes and
stuff a lot of it is about you go like
it's kind of fun but it's also
distracting it's a lot of work you pay a
lot of attention
I actually much prefer just one on
webbing sex one-on-one you're like I'd
say it's the best time but keep going
yeah
because I feel like threesomes foursomes
fight some but it to me you would know
better than anyone but it's a lot of
work and it's like a lot going on he's
got a shot clock
you know cuz you got your primary
partner you can't spend too long it's
like like you're like Phil Jackson you
got all these superstars you gotta make
sure this one you ball this one gets the
ball my ball I mean dick yeah so this
one gets the ball this one gets the ball
then someone's gonna take the
game-winning shot
that means busting in the face you need
Rodman is just willing to clean up the
rebounds you know which means like your
[ __ ]
everybody's Kobe Bryant all things Kobe
Bryant you Derek Fisher you're gonna
suck my [ __ ] from the back yeah yes
Shaquille O'Neal you can get pound it
but I call it heaven that would be my
called stressful no you called so I call
it heaven and where I'm supposed to be
lose my house in the marriage over now
here's the thing such a it's such a
funny thing because it's there's so much
restriction about it and so much like
taboo surrounding is a porn I think but
if you want she said everybody has so
much judgment around it like these are
just pleasure buttons they're like yeah
well [ __ ] each other like we have a
piano but it's like don't play The Black
Keys unless you're [ __ ] in the races
this crazy relationship you know just
play the white ones okay like no play
think we're so we are so ever so uptight
about sex like if you if you're caught
within the amount of shame attached to
sex and being sexual
unless you don't all right I mean you
know I've heard a lot of feminists talk
about how the new wave of feminism is so
sexless it's so repressed so it takes
the romantic out of it
there's no courting it anymore it's kind
of just guys ons gonna take shots no I
can take shots too there were also a lot
of the new feminists sort of like the
Women's Studies like the departments are
all kind of glossed over Marxism anyway
I mean the idea that there's any
difference between men and women
biologically is considered to be
offensive let's say mr. Moore got fired
for it that's a waste of time
that's ridiculous wrong ideology but
like there's some people you watch the I
mean I've seen pornos word you know our
girl I say Cara was pairing me up a bit
I've seen her where she jacks guys off
with her feet yeah yeah there's all kind
I'm not really into that foot thing you
know but I'll like experiment whatever
like yeah the thing is just taking
removing all of the shame and also
removing all the ego thinking that
you've got it figured out thinking that
you're the best like trying to show up I
realized too recently that like a lot of
what I was doing when I was younger is
using other women to validate my own
worth as a man so like if I was able to
do that herd of cows I felt like oh wow
I'm more of a man's like basically put
your true in that splitting of mirror
between everybody's legs and then
looking between and say oh did I do that
well that must mean I'm a man that must
mean I'm good and you don't even enjoy
it when you're doing that ya know just
like it's like it's I got accomplished
it's like yeah it's some weird
validation things yeah it doesn't go
back to not going for the goal it's kind
of good experiencing the process here's
a [ __ ] challenge for people have sex
knowing that your intention has nothing
to do with coming and this is like this
is an interesting product as then you're
totally in the process there's no goal
there's no go orgasm is not the goal
you're just [ __ ] I heard Isis does it
that's it's a don't do it every time as
an older man I've arrived at that that
like really enjoying your big problems
yeah so far I don't think don't you
definitely don't night is still young
you never know well man you know how
devastating it is when you have dick
problems to deal I like young guys tons
of them will talk to me and like they'll
be crying I was that guy man I was the
guy problems okay yeah it for a little
while I had a lot of guys I had a
girlfriend in college that's really mine
[ __ ] me like if I didn't get her off in
a certain way she would like turn her
back and like masturbate in front of me
wouldn't let me touch her blazing you
know how to do it show me I thought I
was it took me like years to get over
that I was actually so nervous about
performance cuz I thought that meant
that I was a man I turned down this
[ __ ] threesome in Australia that just
haunts me to this day
because I turned it down because I was
so nervous that I wouldn't be able to
perform that it was better for me not to
even try the risk potential failure love
bombing I was yeah I was there you know
but when and now with my attitudes like
just [ __ ] go in there play it doesn't
matter it doesn't make you a man or less
of a man whether you your dick stays
hard or not just as long as you're in
the process designer sometimes Edie's
mental - right most of the time
really oh the time think about animals
don't have Edie what's the difference
they're not self-aware they're not
judging themselves old rhinos don't know
those older rhinos don't older horses
not really
they just [ __ ] yes just human a lot of
it so love could be supplements right
depression mental you would be shocked
at the people in the prime of their
testosterone and whatever like just
freaked out and you know talking we talk
about sex a lot and obviously the
relationship with wit and wits like so
many of the girls will meet a new guy
and they like won't be able to perform
because one guys won't be then these are
like young guys and it's all because the
pressure that you put on themselves and
you listen to rap songs you have these
expectations you watch porn you think
you need to do this thing and there's so
much validation you're trying to get
from it's so much pressure it takes the
[ __ ] fun out of ya you know that's
just it sucks because it's like ruining
it's ruining one of the most enjoyable
things that you have when you get your
head all caught up in it so I'm quiet
because that's no really is how ya
people he's just the older man issue but
I can't tell you how painful those years
were for me like so so [ __ ] deeply
deeply long time for like four years a
very common thing for a lot of guys too
is that a lot of ladies men and I know a
couple of them who just beg they've
always put up numbers they get girls
after three months they can no matter
how hot the girl after two months
whatever it is they can't [ __ ] them
anymore and that's another thing because
because they sucked the validation from
it you know and that was the whole thing
they're only interested in it for in the
chase yeah I want to be founded I want
you to once I win once I win you it's
gone it's gone and that that's not
healthy do whatever
what else you got chin and wrong Ginny
Gotti dick game problems you know but I
want to ask you if you guys knew what
sexual transmutation was have you heard
of it
no no it's like you don't come you don't
even jack off on it or anything for a
while because you could focus on all the
stuff that you want to complete and then
all your energy and your focus goes into
that project so you become way more
people do either yes it's at your full I
think [ __ ] still [ __ ] and not come you
know like I don't think you stop [ __ ]
I think the better move is to [ __ ] and
like withhold come like a couple times a
week
no absolutely not but the thing is is
what I like to do go on with my day and
complete because I don't come my brain
goes [ __ ] everything else man let's get
this decision that will work until we
come well it's get to you know about
baseball right and your boy Ben Tim he's
moving up to the double A's which I
don't really know much about but the
Mets are signed to the double A's or
it's a good minute boys he didn't hit
well I've got a cool point old five six
I don't have to look more in I saw it on
mlb.com Tina you've been doing pretty
good they're moving them to always yeah
whatever listen man the people
especially at that level you need
leaders you guys you know these guys
look up to his work ethic everything
he's a piece of an outfielder too so
there's a lot more than just that cool
it's hard to get up at that yeah from
there though it's gonna be a heavy
sledding the general manager said the
owner of Mets said they think he'll play
for the Mets this year no [ __ ] okay yeah
got cut right Tim from the Mets so he
said he's moving up to know so the way
baseball works is so there's a double a
triple a stern triple a right and then
you work your way up
but those teams are associated with the
Mets oh he signed with he play he's been
he's been playing spring ball all with
the New York Mets
yeah oh he's moving now he's in double a
that's a single a triple no next
triple-a triple-a seems like a double-a
triple-a yeah and then Lisa majors
that's tough huh tough road he's doing
it though man doing it's crazy going
around on like buses yeah he's on the
bus with a team everything grinding hey
how much people go the team's [ __ ] he
get told yeah that's willingness to put
yourself out there again you know like
through the New York bats don't be like
God I don't know mitt oh you don't know
you never played sport Union life
you's a Heisman Trophy winner played in
the NFL one day AFC West and then and
then goes oh I'll play baseball and he
plays for the New York Mets oh yeah hate
on that guy
yeah hate on that guy who's closer to
heaven than any of us so humble man like
we're getting on a bus and just you know
I'd be making speeches and just live in
the office watchin just to close out on
that last story the Chicago cop so he
took that guide to the bathroom and also
blew him and then the guy complained got
real frequent we got complained and then
they did DNA testing on that guy's piece
and that's how they found out that that
guy was sucking him off in the bathroom
to some someone say that's a good time
however if you don't want to do that
I mean again did he do it in that dope
leather jacket in the term AK hard and
did he get hard like was he just sucking
hey come on you're shrimping me right
now so how think if you're that get the
victim though where you're like oh my
god and you're like you're I buddy and
tie you down like you're not commit
suicide
I'm good for it I'm good what are you
doing man listen I'm just gonna suck in
your toes and the suckage this guy
obviously had so much [ __ ] shame and
repressed not being able to talk about
it creates these aberrations and now
it's out and now it's [ __ ] out and
then you cross the line you do something
against somebody's will and then that
stop and I got a lot of bad [ __ ] comes
from suppression when you're not
recognize your own recognize if your
freak recognize what that is don't do it
to the suicide of mink go go hire a pro
or something like a guy's Oh tears turn
something tears tears once you get chin
this is a
just let you know so I did you know
those luxury cinemas where they have
those really nice recliner chairs yeah I
love them and everything so this is in
Birmingham England and a guy was he
dropped his phone into one of those
chairs so he went to go on to grab it
and then that recliner started going
down automatically and it chopped his
head so he ended up having a heart
attack
taken to the hospital and then like a
week later he oh but it's not like the
chair crushed he freaked out he freaked
out so hard when it happened so they
finally were lost or foe oh thank god
but I mean most young healthy people
that charity one down it's not gonna
crush your head and kill you I'm sure
you know you can't yeah the what a way
to go man life is short and beer so you
gotta [ __ ] eat what movie was yeah oh
let's do some things I enjoy this thing
man just say what movies good note do
you see by trying and nothing about the
movie it can happen to any of us you
know this could be it right it was
[ __ ] let's [ __ ] it in let's just
enjoy this [ __ ] moments just
shrimping with our friends offered
specially shooter or whatever else you
get chin all right this one has a lot of
funny stuff in it so all those guys are
completely normal though they're both
gay and they had sex with this one has
no chin the other has the biggest ones
and ones an ostrich the other hand visa
began the left looks like the scene in
beetlejuice really sprinkles this both
[ __ ] the same girl you would know who
the daddy
dancer what happened to so they ended up
trying to rob from a guy's house a guy
that they've been boning down with both
been [ __ ] that guy they've been
boning down with him and then there's
still a couple of things like his TV and
some other random stuff AC unit and then
they try to use tomato sauce spaghetti
sauce to burn down the house so they
sort of like older smart - yeah
good-looking and smart they want to make
accident and then so they pour tomato
sauce smell like they put tomato sauce
over the house and sit on some fire on
the stove and then they put a towel
there to hopefully catch on fire the
hostage on fire and they were dressed in
a Bulls outfit one of the guys was
dressed up in a Bulls outfit okay so
they sound like they're what cities is
this in Florida that's like one of the
worst plans ever ever I mean I think
there's some like PCP laws that say I
think there's some shrimping
disassociative miss where's Volusia
County doesn't matter Laura and this is
the guy that got his house almost burned
down I see this guy this is what he
wrote [ __ ] no he's just these trolls
don't see him here he goes it started
out as a relationship that lasted about
a week the victim told them he let them
use a car for four months and then he
thought that maybe they're angry about
that or maybe that the angry that he
gave them a higher for a few dollars to
fix his teeth which I don't really get
too [ __ ] up yeah I needed more money
yeah they look like it's go ahead people
are weird those are the weirdest looking
humans I've ever seen what else you get
Jen not much other than I don't know if
this is super cool guys at all that
LeBron spends a 1.5 million dollars a
year on his body I know I'm guessing
through diet the masseuses all the
training he does the personal trainer on
the road and then he's 32 now I don't
know I think he's 32 and he's the best
he's ever looked and played that's a
tricky thing anyway he's probably got
like a trainer and chefs chefs chefs and
stuff there's also one
25 1.5 million okay well you signed a
billion dollar deal with Nike it's it's
relevant industry like if you spend one
for a lifetime deal Brian a billion
dollars if you look at it like a
business he's a business you know like
if you put a few invest into the
business that's not [ __ ] that is
nothing that's not you know like a
[ __ ] 1.5 percent that's playing the
investment in your business 32 Ray
Kurzweil spends two million dollars
here's something crazy who that up Ray
Kurzweil transcendent man the guy wants
to live until computers catch up so he
can live forever he spends two million
dollars a year I think on supplements so
there's there's another guy Kurzweil
spends a lot I don't think he's the two
million dollar guy there's another dude
like a Russian dude I think I know
you're talking about that guy's like
just try not to do some psychedelics
realized that yeah he's all over the map
LeBron's like doing the most he can so
he can stay at the top of the spear in
the NBA I don't know
either way though that's not that crazy
I'd expect him to do that cool man
ah dude we appreciate you brother I
[ __ ] appreciate you guys to get a
hell of a run coming up you have your
own clothes and shoes now yeah
how the [ __ ] talking on the fashion kid
some [ __ ] hey I need yeah I gotta get
you guys some stuff I'll wear it I gotta
get you guys this one if you want sales
no marriage that's dope and Kenneth yeah
gotta talk to the mechanic jeans yet
shoes shoes I gotta send you some [ __ ]
come on brother
yeah you have good skins don't get the
muscles so they look healthy right now
everyone we were wakeboarding in a
Aubrey was wakeboarding and wake surfing
wake surfing and then he was he had a
shaved head and I was looking at his
body and he has tattoos and he's all
brown and and and I go I go I just kind
of looking at him I go mmm
looked at my arms and I go I'm gonna
shave my head and Brendan goes like this
Brendan if I can mister diplomat goes
bro don't shave your head you're not
gonna look like Aubrey no matter what
you do don't shave your head you'll look
[ __ ] terrible you look like a boiled
yam or something
okay Bob wait the book doesn't drop for
what till April April 17th but you own
the day on your life my Marcus I've read
it it's got a rap nation in it mm-hmm
walking working learning eating training
playing sleeping and sex and they can
get it at Amazon Barnes & Noble Amazon
Barnes & Noble all the options are at on
the day book comm check I'll make this
[ __ ] in New York I appreciate that
appreciate there's there's definitely
some [ __ ] in there that'll that'll wake
you up and make you realize like even
there's from the little random facts
like eating ginger after a meal will
help your stomach empty 50% faster like
a lot of people don't know that [ __ ] so
if you're feeling super full you crush a
bunch of ginger
your stomach empties 50% faster like
most people don't know that I didn't
know that to like you get down into the
research they do PubMed six deep breaths
lower your blood pressure so instead of
taking one breath you take six deep
breath there's like little [ __ ] like
that and then there's the big process so
you know people are gonna get some stuff
way off I dig it man do I dig about that
and I can't thank you enough for coming
in man we know you're busy this is one
of 40 you're doing on this be operate
Marcus I remarked German this is the
finally kid we're out